elena ordena pizzas para una fiesta y
cada pizza ha sido cortada en 12
rebanadas el una quiere que cada persona
en la fiesta alcance 4 rebanadas
entonces cada persona una fiesta con 4
rebanadas y 16 personas asistirán a la
fiesta entonces bueno dice elena compra
7 pizzas y la pregunta es cuántas
rebanadas sobran después de que cada
invitado coma 4 rebanadas ahora para
hacer esto vamos a pensar en cuál será
el total de las rebanadas que tendrá
elena y después pensemos en el total de
rebanadas que serán devoradas por los
invitados y ya con eso tendremos la
cantidad de rebanadas que sobran ahora
pensemos en el total con pausa el vídeo
si quieres si piensa ordeno 7 pizzas
cierto entonces cuántas rebanadas de
pizza habrá en total tiene 7 pizzas es
el número de pizzas 7 pizzas es el
número de pizzas y 12 rebanadas por cada
pizza entonces multiplicamos 7 por 12
para obtener el número
de rebanadas 7 por aquí pongo por 12 y
es el total de rebanadas 12 esto es el
número de rebanadas por pixar entonces
12 es el número de rebanadas por pizza y
multiplicamos 7 por 12 es igual a 84 84
total de rebanadas total de rebanadas
entonces ahora si pensemos en cuál cuál
es el total o bueno cuántas cuántas
rebanadas se comen en total los
invitados tenemos 16 personas que fueron
invitadas a la fiesta es el número de
personas número de personas 16 y cada
uno se come cuatro rebanadas de pizza
eso es muy poco yo tengo muy buen
apetito y no me como solamente cuatro
entonces cuatro rebanadas por cada
persona y multiplicamos 16 por 4 eso es
igual a
eso es igual a 64 es el número de
rebanadas que se comieron en total 64
así que ahora pensemos cuántas rebanadas
sobran entonces vamos a restar iniciamos
la fiesta con 84 rebanadas y 64 fueron
devoradas por los invitados entonces 84
menos 64 es igual a 20 rebanadas que
sobraron y ahí lo tenemos entonces
bastante divertido este problema me
gustó me gustó nos vemos pronto